The first full trailer for Zack Snyder's Justice
League just dropped and it does a great job
teasing some incredible action scenes.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'm taking a look at some
interesting details you might have missed
and connections in the trailer to the wider
DC cinematic universe.
Quick warning: obviously, there's speculation
and potential spoilers ahead for the Justice
League movie.
Let's start with all the hints and teases
in the trailer to the mother boxes, which,
as we know from the deleted scene in Batman
V Superman, will be key to the plot of the
Justice League movie.
The first mother box appears in a scene with
Silas Stone, the scientist from STAR Labs
who appeared in the metahuman video case file
that Diana Prince, aka Wonder Woman, watched
in Batman v Superman.
In that short scene, we saw a motherbox in
STAR Labs react with the amputated body of
Silas's son, Victor Stone, to create Cyborg.
Back in the Justice League trailer, it looks
like that motherbox is being activated again
and, as it does so, a Parademon appears just
behind Silas.
And in another shot, it also looks like Cyborg
is carrying or dragging a motherbox beside
him.
By the way, did you notice the football trophies
in this shot which link to the scene later
in the trailer of Silas's son Vic playing
in a football game?
And that of course fits in with the comics
where Vic Stone was a top football player.
Later in the trailer, there's a scene of the
Apokoliptian army fighting the Amazon army,
and this could be part of the movie's opening
sequence to establish the history of Darkseid's
attempts to invade the Earth and set up the
reasons why he sent Steppenwolf to search
for the mother boxes.
The previous Comic Con trailer showed a mother
box being buried, and we know that the Amazons
were given one of the other boxes with the
third going to the Atlanteans.
For the third mother box, there's a possible
hint to its location in this underwater shot
of Mera.
By the way, in the comics, Mera is the Queen
of Atlantis and Aquaman's wife.
Speaking of Aquaman, he gets to do some very
cool stuff in the new trailer, including riding
on the outside of the Batmobile and splitting
the ocean with his trident.
And I also enjoyed the scene of Bruce Wayne
journeying to the fishing village where we
see Aquaman.
These very cinematic shots of a snowy wilderness
are likely footage from the production's shoot
in Iceland.
The scene with Bruce Wayne meeting Barry Allen
already appeared in the Comic Con footage
released by Warner Bros, but the next shot
is a very cool look at The Flash travelling
through the speed force.
Notice the incredibly powerful streaks not
only moving around him but also on his suit.
And according to set visits, the Flash's suit
is wrapped in wires in order to contain the
electricity he generates when he's speeding.
Later in the trailer, we also see a brief
glimpse of Barry's father Dr Henry Allen,
played by Billy Crudup.
In the comics and also the TV show, Henry
Allen is imprisoned when he's wrongly convicted
for the murder of Barry's mother.
Now, the shot you see here is of a tunnel
that was intended to connect Gotham to Metropolis
but was abandoned in the 1930s.
Set visits have also revealed that this will
be part of a key action scene with Batman,
The Flash and Wonder Woman battling a horde
of Parademons.
The vehicle they're using is also new for
Justice League and it's called the Night Crawler.
It's an all-terrain vehicle that can move
through all kinds of rough and difficult environments,
and, if you look carefully, you'll see it
forming itself into a kind of spider-tank.
And in the next shot, it's even climbing vertically
right up the walls of this ventilation shaft.
We also get to see the new Batmobile in action
and it's been updated since Batman V Superman,
with the addition of new guns on the front
and sides, plus there's a cannon on top.
And it wouldn't be a superhero movie or trailer
without a superhero landing, right?
But what I liked about this shot was the visual
similarities with Wonder Woman heading up
a trio of superheroes, just like she did in
Batman V Superman.
Some fans might be disappointed that there
was no Superman in this trailer, but we do
get a shot of Lois Lane as she turns around
to look up at something off camera.
Which makes me wonder whether that 'something'
will be the Man of Steel making his return.
So, what did you think of the Justice League
trailer?!
Did it get you hyped for the movie and were
there any easter eggs or things you noticed?
Let me know in the comments below!
And if you enjoyed this, I really appreciate
you hitting that like button and why not subscribe
for more of my easter egg and comic book movie
videos.
Check out some more videos you might like
right here.
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!